la rumeur de la semaine ça concerne
céline dion puisque céline dion on a
toutes annoncé qu'elle souffrait de
trucs incroyables alzheimer un cancer
des spasmes fibromyalgie qu'elle ne
viendrait pas en europe on sait où est
ce qu'elle est bête avec ses enfants pas
ses enfants on a le spécialiste mondial
la france va mon le monde entier le veut
le canada nous l'a demandé même pour
parler de céline dion c'est florian
ronsin il est avec nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'accord c'est sain
[Applaudissements]
il n'est pas né
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parisi vite
merci beaucoup
on se calme leur est grave elle est
malade si vous voulez qu'elle refasse un
jour pourrait peut-être déjà qu'elle se
soigne faut alors casque est d'abord
allé ou en ce moment elle habite où elle
est ou alors actuellement elle est à las
vegas une résidence d'ultralu avec des
personnes qui sont sur millionnaire je
suis prudent elle vit dans une résidence
où il ya tout médecin pharmacie un
immense centre commercial en cas
d'accord pas besoin de sortir de sa
résidence mais elle est alité non à la
fin elle elle est alité souvent wen doit
aujourd'hui elle recommencer à sortir
elle est avec ses trois enfants est dit
nelson et rené char il ya aussi une de
ses soeurs qui l'aident à s'occuper de
ses enfants parce que on sait qu'elle
est un peu fatigués l'armée devrait
alors elle a eu au mois de janvier on a
annoncé qu'elle avait des spasmes
musculaires s'est allié à une maladie
dakar heures de fatigue aujourd'hui on
dit qu'elle va mieux sur ce côté là mais
comme elle est très très maigre et que
pendant sa phase de convalescence elle a
encore perdu du poids aujourd'hui elle
est suivie par ce qu'elle a des spasmes
d'alex attend tant que chien depuis deux
mois et demi parce qu'avec un spasfon ça
passerait qu'elle a d'énormes e du grand
maître comme elle est très très minces
aujourd'hui elle a encore perdu du poids
dont elle est suivie à des
nutritionnistes qui s'occupe d'elle il
est allé dans la de lui redonner un peu
de la forme et du tonus puisque faire
une tournée ça prend du temps et ça
demande beaucoup d'énergie et
aujourd'hui elle est en train d'être
remise en forme est normalement si tout
va bien au mois de mai elle sera de
retour sur scène en europe lors que
l'europe n'est pas du tout nu oui
puisque la bonne nouvelle c'est que
lundi on a appris que ce les équipes de
céline dion ont confirmé à la salle de
concert parisienne donc l'iphone a donc
ses maillots arenas à la défense arena
rue que l'ecosoc et les concerts aurait
bien lieu et ils ont réservé les deux
étages de l'hôtel où elle descend
régulièrement quand elle vient à paris
et dont l ocl et déjà réservez donc ça
ce sont des signes qui montrent que en
effet la tournée et elle
va être de fins mais jusqu'à fin
septembre dans l'hôtel parisien est même
un peu plus ce commencé qu'elle adore la
fashion week elle va certainement faire
la fashion-week d'été et celle d'hiver
chaignat dans un hôtel qu'on ne citera
pas voilà je connais bien et qui a
toujours le même d'ailleurs par haare
est une petit peu natation voilà qui se
terminera exactement un apparat z
n'apparaît air
mercure
il faudra que qu'à la fff demande de
l'aide jean michel cohen nutritionniste
oui parce que l'europe a besoin de
reprendre un peu de poids d'accord parce
que pour faire de la scène pendant un
mois ou d'accord lui faut vraiment avoir
des vrais biscotos et bien sûr c'est
vrai ce que tu as fait beaucoup de scène
et non
sa place
et est surtout le mental et c'est bien
gentil une vraie question il en est quoi
de des rumeurs de démence c'est avéré
c'est faux elle parle à rené qu'est-ce
qui se passe non elle a toujours eu une
relation très fusionnelle avec rené on
le sait il est décédé maintenant il ya
six ans et que très vite après que rené
soit décédée elle est remontée sur scène
à la demande de rené et à l'effet
mouillé autrui elle n'a jamais arrêté
ses lyrics une fois qu'il a fini les
gars salaire et sa tournée mondiale
quand elle est en pause à vegas elle
venait en europe ou au japon faire d
énormes concert et elle a toujours dit
qu'elle continuerait de lui parler
qu'elle est en relation permanente avec
lui elle touche encore la folie cause
c'est vrai que c'est vrai qu'à la peine
à une moulure de de kwaga c'est la
moulure de saman il allait les termes
signe oui les pouces et il faisait un
signe avec leurs doigts qui était tout
va bien aller et donc justement les
moules et sa main puisque remis une
feuille puma justement dire qu'elle est
seule dans cette grande baraque mais
aider précise je pense qu'elle est tres
elle a toujours été accompagnée de rené
viale qui depuis qu'elle a 15 ans a
toujours été avec elle il a toujours
tout gérer les enfants sont arrivés mais
ils ne sont pas h 24 avec elle et puis
ils grandissent rené-charles aujourd'hui
est très souvent au canada il n'est pas
souvent à elle à adhamiyah n'a pas
d'amis elle a dit
people ils vivent tous à los angeles
elle reste à vegas puisque aston de la
musique ne valent alors qu'elle est très
proche de katy perry aujourd'hui puisque
[Rires]
ce que dans sa biographe aussi sa chance
y vivent et y aller sa biographe merci
lors c'est toujours sa biographe qui
parle beaucoup aujourd'hui dans les
différents journaux a parlé chez nous
notamment à 12 heures elle explique
qu'elle a fait deux dépressions
successives la première à la mort de
rené et la deuxième à la mort de sa mère
dont elle était très proche en 2020
quatre ans plus tard donc les vrais elle
est toujours dans cette dynamique
négative ou et tu sais quoi la réponse
est dans une seconde parce que vous dira
aussi est ce que oui ou non aujourd'hui
elle a un amant vous allez être surpris
de la réponse à tout alors les amis on
était avec florian ronsin qui nous
arrive du québec pour nous parler d'eux
vous n'êtes pas l'accent d'ailleurs jean
pas du tout c'est vrai qu'on tendait
très moisis mi-temps vient donner aussi
à temps je te crève c'était un homme en
plus tu te fais vraiment c'est à dire
mon but ce film j'ai toujours bien aimé
faut que j'ai vu j'ai su garder mon but
ce filon alors il sait qu'il est fou
derrière c'est pas ta meilleur temps et
bien c'est vrai asie faire mieux mais je
préfère johnny allait vraiment content
d'être là ces gens il est bon c'est pas
les meilleurs on s'emmerde à ces mythes
préfet - monsieur monsieur je sais tout
du monde fait passer maintenant mais la
nuit j'ai pas la prétention de géorgie
mythe contrairement à toi
[Applaudissements]
tu te calmes alors on va parler a donc
jamais une question c'est la dernière
mais franchement on nous prend pour base
la bestiole un an paris est mort il ya
six ans évidemment c'est très triste
évidemment elle a forcément fait le
deuil à la 55 ans en vrai de vrai céline
ya quand même des moments où
je pense que céline dion n'est pas une
femme sexuelle georges une fille
sexuelle tu veux dire c'est que tu es
par non c'est une personne qui vit de
plein qui jouit de plein de choses de
ses enfants de l'amour de ses proches
alors c'est maladroit de presse des oui
non mais je pense que c'est quelqu'un il
s'enivre de la vie elle a pas besoin je
pense d'avoir des relations sexuelles
chanson elle est très amoureuse de son
mari j'adore qu'elle retrouve quelques
uns mais l'on pense pas qu'elle sera à
nouveau en couple c'est qu'on appelle à
l appel d aventure est là parce que
c'est quelqu'un qui vit de la chanson
qui vit de cissé et relation avec le
ppe-de amical à elle elle adore être
allez allez on y va à monsieur lui
faisant des fans donc on s'en est fini
mais les stylistes alors mais
moi j'ai partagé linate heures du matin
mais quand des poteries elle pouvait
peut-être club des petites choses des
petites choses comme ça dans le noir
jamais lorient vous avez suivi pendant
six ans c'est vrai il ya eu l'histoire
avec le styliste
s'est aussi demandée on s'est posé la
question sur son peut-être orientation
sexuelle on s'est demandé à ce qu'elle
aime pas les femmes ce qu'elles aient
pas se mettre plus souhaité
l'accompagner évoluer changer ça mais
voilà peut-être aussi c'est pour cela
pose en corner mais oui on se la pose
tout est au conditionnel et façon quelle
que soit la réponse est et ce qu'elle
veut et un verre à la main rené en cire
la lame un drone et
il s'alimente
au chant et danse
était intouchable céline dion attend
deux mon corps à demi nu vous quittez
pas deux minutes oui mathieu pour la
région notamment avec céline aux séries
l'homme était gentil il aime bien aller
il est gentil
copie ok c'est bon ça c'est réglé ça
s'est réglé des amis maintenant bas on
remercie notre québécois
[Applaudissements]